malraux a dit l'art est le plus court
chemin de l'homme à l'homme est comme
moi j'aimerais que vous rencontrez de
vous connaître
j'ai décidé que pendant une heure on
allait parler d'art monnaie qui peint
l'entrée de giverny sous la neige
on sent déjà une vraie volonté de vider
le tube de blanc la grande question
c'est des cymbales hills est-ce qu'il y
en a des meilleurs que nous qui est le
rostropovitch de la cymbale vous allez
voir prendre le spectacle moi j'aime
comme ça posé les grandes questions mais
parfois je me fiche de la réponse c'est
ma part de féminité
j'adore les potins si seulement il
pouvait parler de gens que je connais et
oui alors moi mon rêve si vous les
suzerains voici mes culturel le mélange
entre voici et télérama ramassis oui
c'est vrai j'aime lire thomass man
oui j'aime les films de bergman
oui j'aime la musique de schumann mais
moi ce que j'aime par dessus tout et
baisers des salles aussi pu terminer ma
vie sur une île déserte
j'ai le choix entre marguerite duras et
pamela anderson ou le choisit pamela
anderson déjà par sécurité